come on Internet this is what we can't
have nice PC games
apparently general I've just came out on
PC and 24 hours later there are naked
versions of all the characters
the one thing that team ninja
specifically asked was hey no naked
ladies the first thing that happened
naked ladies
I'm drew Coolidge and yes we're gonna
show you some of them this is hashtag
news Tim ninja put it out there that
they wanted users to play the game in
good moral and manner they're like
please play this game filled with
half-naked women in good more home
manner these women are as close to naked
already as you could be team ninja did
all they could to meet you halfway like
take a look at this one there's only
flower petals covering her nipples and
you guys were so brief that you're like
I can't just imagine what's behind that
I need to know what's behind that they
put in the jiggle effect just for you
guys there are accurate chests physics
happening just for you what Pixar did in
monsters Inc for moving hair team ninja
did for boob physics and just I don't I
don't think you guys are realizing what
you're putting your energy towards you
guys went through so much work in that
24 hours you change the color so that
there's areolas you put nipples there's
work done down stairs instead of making
a nipple
maybe just you know set up an OkCupid
profile you can see real live boobs and
then tell me what they look like but now
you had to do it and now guess what team
min just said they're not gonna make any
more PC games just think about how many
almost nude amazing PC games we could
have had almost nude organ trail
partially nude Mavis Beacon teaches
typing pantsless Crash Bandicoot
Dead or Alive 6 if you want to say
someone naked so bad just follow me on
snapchat I'm very active I'm naked from
the waist down right now yeah we know
that's all first here at hashtag news
hit like if you kinda are interested in
seeing more nude mods
let's be honest comment with your
favorite video games that you wish had
nude mods Donkey Kong this
he's not wearing that tie Diddy bitty
titty Kong just came up with the heck
you're welcome you can use that and hit
subscribe because we've bringing stories
like this one hard-hitting nude mod
videos hit it or quit but don't quit it
just hit subscribe
I'm drew Coolidge and let's get this
shirt off oh my god oh it's just put
your feet balls guys I thought you had
colorful tumors
[Music]